was
miss heard cast in aquaman
yes she was
was miss heard cast in aquaman too
yes she was
was miss heard paid
for her services in aquaman one
yes
was miss heard paid for her services in
aquaman too
yes
was her compensation
for aquaman 2
affected in any way by anything said by
johnny depp
no
was her compensation for aquaman
who
affected by anything said by adam
waldman
no
was
her compensation for aquaman ii affected
by anything said by anybody
representing johnny depp
no
was there any delay
in warner brothers exercising the option
to cast
misheard and aquaman fear
yes it was
how long a delay was there
um
i don't know it probably weeks
what was the cause of the delay
uh there were conversations about
potentially recasting
was the producer uh peter saffron
who was the director
uh james juan
did warner brothers believe that those
concerns were legitimate
uh yeah i mean i had no reason not to
believe the director and producer of the
movie
and you are testifying today the
representative of your correct
yes i am
what if any creative concerns
did warner brothers have
about asking
amber heard as mira in aquaman 2.
it was the concerns that were brought up
at the wrap of the first movie
production first movie which is the
issue of chemistry did the two epic
chemistry
um you know i think editorially they
were able to make that relationship work
in the first movie but there was a
concern that it took a lot of effort to
get there
and would we be better off
recasting finding someone who had better
more natural chemistry with pizza momoa
and move forward in that one
did warner brothers
take any steps
affirmatively to
audition other
actresses for the role of meera and
aquaman too
no we did not
other than the creative concerns and
concerns about chemistry you testified
about
was there any other reason
warner brothers delayed in picking up
mrs option
more aquaman too
no it was all it was all concerns about
whether she was the right bit of casting
for the movie
what role if any
did
miss herds dispute with johnny depp
have in warner brothers delay
picking and picking up
miss heard option were aquaman too
there was there was none from our end
you